The Joe Rogan Experience
because we did Hot Yoga then I came back
we did hot yoga for your show that was
fun yeah that was dope that was fun that
was fun then Vice ran out of money and
uh you know couldn't do the show anymore
well somebody got money didn't Shane
Smith made me think it's about a loot
Shane's a man yeah I love that dude I
still talk to Shane but uh no it was I
think the end of Wong's world was just
they were like yo we still want to do
Wong's world but can we make it domestic
and I wanted to do films and I was just
saying love you I'm gonna go I'm gonna
go make this film so they wanted to do
it in the United States because of uh
travel costs yeah yeah and just because
viceland the first couple years it was
just the the accounting was off on on if
people were just spending money crazy
bro it started out they would take these
guys with glasses on these nerds and
send them over to like the middle of a
goddamn war zone these two to be filming
the flak jacket on yeah bombs are
blowing off in the Middle East and
they're just reporting there you're like
whoa oh vices why yeah it was the best
because it was vice would just pick the
most dangerous [__] and be like here's
thirty thousand dollars go with it like
you know 5D camera yeah and [__] come
back with some footage and try not to
die
and then once it became the TV channel
it got it got crazy because I mean I was
probably the biggest perpetrator so like
all in all fairness to Shane somebody
needed to be like Eddie you're burning
money crazy because I was going to like
F1 tracks and and I literally the last
episode I went on the F1 track in Abu
Dhabi and Shane was there and he's like
what are you doing here you're a [__]
food show and I was like I don't know I
got him from inside this car
it's like getting caught by your boss
oh you're gonna try formula one food bro
yeah yeah yeah yeah I was like I'm gonna
try the concessions dude they sent David
Cho to the Congo to look for a dinosaur
have you ever seen that yeah the most
ridiculous [__] of all time it might be
the greatest Vice episode ever bro it's
an amazing episode yeah that in uh
hymo's Arctic Adventure that's my
favorite one that's the one about that
dude who lives in Alaska he's
subsistence survives in this very small
cabin yeah he's the last person that's
allowed to own this cabin in this
Wilderness I haven't seen it whoa that
one's heavy That's Heavy but that that's
the the chill episode's the best because
there's so many people now especially in
La that are like for a honeymoon or like
for the holidays I'm gonna go to the
Congo I wanna I wanna go to West Africa
and I'm just like bro watch that episode
real quick yeah watch that episode
that's not where you're staying but it's
close to where you you trying to go like
check check that episode out you're in
the middle of a conflict Zone it's very
dangerous being down there you know uh
it's just
and probably no dinosaurs no no there's
probably no dinosaurs I want to go to
Ethiopia but I'm not going with chill
wherever chill went I'm like I'm not
going it was wild man he went when he he
camped with the hanza he stayed with the
haza and went hunting with them yeah he
was saying that when they shot they were
shooting baboons to eat and he said it's
crazy when they shoot a baboon it grabs
the arrow and like you see it grabbed
out you're like yo that's a little too
weird you know
Cho was really putting himself in danger
oh yeah I was like I was more like the
Vanderpump well you know I mean I was
like let's have a nice
one yeah let's give it up people
beautiful land yeah see some [__]
people here have a good time stayed in a
nice hotel yeah I chose like the
opposite of conflict zones